zu den favoriten für den preis des
besten films zählen für mich die drei
filme first ever really sometimes aways
und schwesterlein chris cao der
spätwestern der gleichzeitig eine
liebeserklärung an die natur ist und von
der freundschaft zweier männer erzählt
never really is always die ergreifende
geschichte einer jugendlichen abtreibung
sehr dezent und mit einer große
intensität gespielt von zwei jungen
bisher noch völlig unbekannten
schauspielerin und schwesterlein zeigt
in den hauptrollen lars eidinger und
nina hoss als ein geschwisterpaar und
erzählt auf ruhige und gleichwohl guten
und weise von den letzten legen nämlich
dem abschied und dem frühen krebstod
die drei deutschen wettbewerbsbeiträge
haben eigentlich alle überzeugt sie
jedenfalls keine enttäuschung obwohl man
sagen muss dass undine von pätzold und
vor allem schwesterlein doch die das
trio anführt und wenn ihn alexanderplatz
dann zum schluss kommt ist also im
ganzen muss man einfach sagen dass es
ein großes spektrum hier zu sehen gab an
unterschiedlichen seelen bildern an
unterschiedlichen berührungspunkten die
man haben konnte es wurde von
freundschaft von liebe von krankheit von
tod erzählt fazit unterm strich ein
wirklich ereignisreiches spannendes und
bewegendes festival das dieses 70
jubiläum der berlinale angemessen zeigt
und feiert und beweist dass das neue
führungsduo dieser stadt etwas zu bieten
hat